[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with the new
statesman's deputy online editor rachel
kunliff and the writer benedict spence
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so straight to the front
pages then let's start with the
telegraph quoting from rishi sunak's
speech to the tory party conference in
which he said businesses have become
drunk on cheap labor
also carries the chancellor's words this
time saying he's determined to tackle
borrowing
p.m to tell britain get back to work
that's on the front of the mail ahead of
boris johnson's address to the
conference later this week
the guardian has more on the so-called
pandora papers leaked documents which
allegedly call into question whether
some donations to the conservatives were
above board
the times reports that the government
plans to sack nhs managers who fail to
get their waiting lists under control
according to the metro the founder of
the environmental protest group
extinction rebellion has said it would
be acceptable for demonstrators to block
ambulances if it meant getting their
message across
that story also making the front page of
the star
while the financial times reports that
the price of u.s crude oil is now at a
seven year high
the sun hears that dame arlene phillips
will soon join itv's dancing on ice as a
judge several years after she left
strictly come dancing
so let's bring in rachel connor from
benedict expense welcome then to both of
you um to the daily mail first of all an
exclusive they say by jason groves uh
looking ahead to what he's going to say
later this week which is get back to
work but that really means get back to
your desk does it rachel
yeah it's fine i thought i already had
been at work the last 18 months and i
feel like many people looking at this
this headline will will see the same um
actually one of the few silver linings
from the pandemic has been a successful
transition to remote working flexible
working some variation of of working
from home now if this front page gives
you a bout of deja vu you're not going
mad we did see basically this exact
headline uh last summer when the prime
minister and rishi sanat were urging us
to get back to the office and we know
that their plans were derailed by
another covered wave and actually in the
winter lockdown they were putting up
posters saying how dare you go to work
you're responsible for spreading covert
so a lot of back and forth a lot of
mixed messaging
over the last year when it comes to to
what work is and whether the government
wants you to be doing it but the point
that boris johnson is making here is
basically that people work better more
productively when they can see their
colleagues face to face they learn more
and therefore they should jolly well go
out and do it whether you agree with
that is another question entirely he
believes very strongly in the value of
face-to-face working a senior source
told this uh jason groves political
editor of the mail it is critical for
the training and development of young
people how can you learn a new job on
zoom i think a lot of people had to do
education on zoom did they not um but
this is uh the paper says amid growing
confidence that covid will not spark
further lockdowns so the basis of this
is the government's very happy to hit
what roughly 35 000 covid cases a day as
we continue into into winter is that is
that the bottom line on this uh do you
think
i think you have to sort of look a
little bit away from the actual covert
bit i do think that this is an attempt
to draw a line under this particular
episode of covid but as rachel's pointed
out you know that can always be road
back on um i actually think the point of
saying you know let's get us all back to
work is actually if you look sort of in
the wider you know the wider situation
when you have things like you know empty
shelves and you have uh shortages of
fuel and you have all of these sorts of
issues i think what this is it's a sort
of a it's a similar kind of a nudge if
you like to what we had uh when the
prime minister was saying well you know
regulations again you know code
regulations are going to have to be put
in place because people aren't following
the guidelines which is leading to
covert cases soaring what this is i
think is trying to switch the narrative
uh when it comes to the issues of for
example uh haulage drivers shortages
supermarket workers shortages it's
saying people aren't at work and what we
need to do is get people back to work
it's putting the onus on the public uh
surrounding an awful lot of external
crises that are happening at the moment
and trying to shift blame away if you
like uh from the government and its
covered policies uh and obviously focus
on brexit which the government
absolutely does not want to be blamed
for anything that's going wrong at the
moment yeah the daily telegraph picks up
on where we're at effectively and the
question i suppose um looking looking at
what the prime minister is hoping for is
how do you bounce back when you have
things like a supply crisis you know the
fuel crisis uh the how do you how many
pigs have to die and not get to market
crisis rachel how much will it hamper
their hopes for growth at this stage
i never thought i would see a front page
like that of a telegraph of the
telegraph coming out from a conservative
government i remember the boris johnson
using an expletive with regards to to
business which i won't repeat on air uh
and various people making the points a
few years ago uh that the crore party is
traditionally the party of business the
party of enterprise and commerce and
this is a very very clear sign that
that's not where this conservative party
is at the moment at all uh the the
argument is if there are supply chain
issues if there are shortages if
businesses can't function properly well
sorry businesses you knew brexit was
coming uh it's up to you to source it
out now and i have some sympathy with
that argument i think uh if there were
firms that were um holding out in hope
that maybe brexit wouldn't happen
then that seems quite quite naive purely
from a business continuity perspective
they did have time to prepare however as
late as december last year there were
days to go until the transition
agreement running out firms were still
finding it virtually impossible to find
advice and guidance from the government
and what they were meant to do there
were there was a website set up that
didn't have any information there were
questions about what forms you need to
fill in that even the government didn't
seem to know so the idea that business
is particularly small businesses could
have prepared for this in the midst of a
pandemic with everything else that was
going on
given no guidance from the government
and that therefore if there are
shortages now it is their fault and also
our fault the public for wanting things
like turkey and pigs in blanket and
petrol i i think is really as bended was
saying shifting the blame from
the government that could maybe have
helped a little bit possibly onto
businesses and individuals and uh sorry
benedict i i haven't stolen your idea
but i do have a column and the new state
has been out on exactly this topic that
you can all read tomorrow
i mean this is this has sort of been the
narrative of today the sort of the the
mood at the tory party conference versus
what business has to say the the
ambition of homegrown well-paid labor
but what happens in the interim is what
business is asking how much pain do you
have to suffer in the interim to get to
that end result and that has there been
an answer on that do you think is this
this or this all falls into this
christmas shortage problem uh but
instead of actually worrying about uh
you know what you can do about it
blaming saying it was a failure of the
free market not the state at this point
benedict
i mean
in many ways actually this is a quite a
good advert for brexit because what is
what we've you know a lot of practices
wanted was for governments to take a
little bit more responsibility and now
the government is going to have to take
a little bit more responsibility but
also businesses are going to have to
take a little bit more responsibility
and they're going to have to own up to
the fact that ultimately a lot of people
have been sort of muddling along in this
country both in government and in
business hoping that everything will be
all right on the night and not you know
not anticipating something like a
pandemic which sort of shows up all of
your flaws i mean the difficulty is you
know what we're hearing now aren't we
talking about potentially uh relaxing
visa registrations for certain jobs that
sort of thing but ultimately i don't
think that that's going to solve the
issue this was always going to be
actually a very painful period of the
brexit process regardless of covet
because you can't simply switch an
economy that has you know become used to
running a certain way and running on a
certain type of labor uh to another type
overnight especially when you have a
population a domestic population which
is under trained for a lot of the jobs
that are are going to be expected for
those people to take on and as as you've
already pointed out anna if people have
been learning via zoom for the password
of 18 months that sort of hampers the
process even more if you only have a
short number of people working in the
dvla for example doing hgv licenses and
they're all you know working from home
these are all things that do end up
piling up so i think you can take covid
and say that that certainly affected all
of this it would be very churlish to say
that it hasn't but this as brexiteers
and remainers alike have been pointing
at pointing out for a very long time
this was always going to be a painful
transition uh from what it was that we
had to what it is boris johnson and er
envisions
and very very quickly rachel it was only
last week that grant chaps proudly were
saying they brought in 18 measures to
tackle this issue both of which were on
the front pages one in the ft uh which
is the the military have started
refilling stations the second one on the
front page of the times which is this
offer for temporary visas uh which the
paper says has only attracted 27 fuel
drivers if you look at that this is not
solvable soon
i'm not surprised they've only got 27
applications given that the terms were
come over here work really hard save our
christmas and then off you go on on
christmas eve there's another point in
the in the ft flagging that actually a
lot of the drivers who might want these
jobs come from outside of the eu and
therefore don't have the recognized uh
credentials in order to take them so
you've got that issue as well and the
government is very much trying to frame
this as it will drive up prices and
that's good because we want a well-paid
economy for people struggling on poverty
wages which is a valid argument and is
very fair what they don't seem to
mention is that that will drive up
prices prices of fuel and particularly
prices of food at a time when they're
ending universal credit on wednesday
fellow has just ended we've got energy
price spike so energy bills are going to
significantly soar up over the winter
period they've got new tax coming in in
april basically cost of living crisis
it's coming okay exactly and any wage
increases the point is will be gobbled
up by the cost of living exactly that um
plenty more still to come including as
the met police announces a review into
its standards and culture we'll ask what
lessons might be learned more on that in
a moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now rachel connell and ben and
expense welcome back to both of you and
so benedict then inside pages of the
metro uh once again uh discussing uh the
problems for the met with this internal
review announced um about time some
might say i don't know what your
feelings are
oh well i mean about time i think i
think it's well over time frankly uh
that the last sort of 18 months have
been pretty lamentable actually for the
metropolitan police and i mean yeah if
you were to just to take this
really appalling story uh of the sarah
everard story out of the equation you
look at the sort of the policing of the
the vigil around it the policing of the
protests that have gone on uh in london
you know over the last few years on both
sides here sort of pro lock down
anti-lock down black lives matter all of
these things
it's just not been a particularly good
time
and as much as anything else it's really
eroded trust i think from the public
with regards to the police
and right now when you need actually you
know so what everybody sort of be
supposed to be pulling together all
sorts of extraordinary powers being
passed really trust is the absolute
foundation the cornerstone of it and i i
really i think that this has just come
far too far in the day this should have
happened a long time ago actually as the
story was unfolding and yeah it's
perhaps not my place to say but i do
think that this shouldn't be enough
really to prolong crested dick in her
position
um and i'm going to move on to the next
story because i've only got 30 seconds
left rachel i probably i'm gonna i'm
going to cut you off again i know the
global glitch knocks out facebook apps
uh it's a biggie this one
i'm loving it i'm embracing my twitter
dms uh but but yes it's been down for
hours and in a sign of the seriousness
of this facebook can't fix it because
staff can't communicate with each other
because their in-house communication
platforms are all powered by basically
the same thing great powers facebook
rachel and benedict thank you both very
much indeed